let's try to subtract 164 from 301 and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try it on your own first so let's go
place by place and we can realize where
we have to do some borrowing or
regrouping so the ones place we have an
issue 4 is larger than 1 how do we
subtract a larger number from a smaller
number we also have an issue in the tens
place 6 is larger than 0 how do we
subtract 6 from 0 so the answer that
might be jumping into your head is oh
we've got to do some borrowing or some
regrouping but then you might be facing
another problem you would say ok well
let's try to borrow from the tens place
here so we have a 1 if we could borrow
10 from the tens place could be at 11
but there's nothing here in the tens
place there's nothing to borrow so what
do we do so the way I would tackle it is
first borrow for the tens place so we
have nothing here so let's regroup a
hundred from the hundreds place so
that's equivalent to borrowing a 1 from
the hundreds place so that's now a 2 and
now in the tens place instead of a 0
instead of a 0 we are going to have a 10
now let's make sure that this still
makes sense this is 200 plus 10 10 10 10
is a hundred plus 1 200 plus 100 plus 1
is still 301 so this still makes sense
and the reason why this is valuable is
now we have something to regroup from
the tens place if we take one of these
tens one of these tens so now we're left
with nine tens and we give it we give it
to the ones place so you give 10 plus
one you're going to be left with you're
going to be left with 11 and we can
verify that we still haven't changed the
value of the actual number 200 plus 90
is 290 plus 11 is still 301 and what was
neat about this is now up here all of
these numbers are larger than the
corresponding number in the same place
so we get we're ready to subtract
11 minus 4 11 minus 4 is let's see oh
let's see 10 minus 3 is 7 so 11 minus 4
is 7 9 minus 6 is
three and two minus one is one so we are
left with 137